annie jacobson is next on book tv
the author recounts the us government's
clandestine program to employ german
scientists following world war ii
the program dubbed operation paperclip
brought several scientists and their
families to the united states despite
the fact that many were accused of war
crimes
this is a little under an hour
thank you so much good evening everybody
um i am annie jacobson
i want to thank book passage for having
me
it's really delightful to be here and
thank you all so much for coming there's
nothing uh
that makes this author happier than
meeting readers so thank you
tonight i'm going to be talking uh about
operation paperclip
and i'm going to tell you a little bit
about what the program was
i'm going to tell you a little bit about
how i became interested in writing and
researching and reporting operation
paperclip
and then i'm going to end by telling you
some very um what i think are
interesting ways in which the story gets
reported
so
to start with
my book operation paperclip
these
gentlemen are 21 of approximately
1600
german scientists who came to america
to work for the us military and
intelligence agencies after the war i
focus on these men because i found them
to be particularly unique and
interesting and somewhat nefarious on
varying degrees
and
i think it's important to also
realize that whenever you're reporting a
story like this
it's about
riding on the heels of many important
journalists and historians who have come
before so while i do bring lots of new
information to the table
academics also have been involved in
unearthing this story over the decades
but i think now there's really a a a
light cast on operation paperclip that
has not been shown before
the story for me began when i was
reporting this book area 51 and when i
was working on that i came across these
two nazi aircraft designers
named uh walter and rymar horton
and they were working on this aircraft
which looks a lot like the b2 bomber so
you can immediately see that you know
hitler's weapons were very interesting
to the allies during the war and
immediately after
um
i found out when i was researching the
horton brothers that he had a boss
and when he was at the luftwaffe he
worked for hermann goring and there's
goring with hitler the luftwaffe was the
german air force
but in between
the horton brothers and harman goring
was this guy and this is siegfried
nehemiah
colonel siegfried knight and during the
war he was one of the reich's top ten
pilots he flew on spy missions over
norway to decide which was the best
places to bomb
and siegfried kneemar was also an
incredibly talented engineer so as he
rose up through the ranks he caught the
attention of goring
who made him chief of all technical and
engineering developments
and
goring felt that nehemiah was so
important to him that he called him my
boy
now i found out when i was researching
nehemiah that nehemiah came to the
united states
and worked under this program which i at
the time did not know anything about was
called operation paperclip
and i thought to myself how does this
work
how do you go from having goring as a
boss
to having the pentagon as a boss
and not only that when nehemiah retired
in the middle
1970s he was given the
distinguished civilian service award
which is the highest award that the
department of defense can give to a
non-uniformed
person
so operation paperclip to understand
about operation paperclip you really
must go back to the fall of 1944
and it was a very dark time this is a
map from william shires rise and fall of
the third reich
and you see that we've landed at
normandy and we've we're pushing toward
munich and berlin
and
among the soldiers
are scientists with the u.s military
and they're part of a secret mission
called operation al sauce
and the mission of alsace is to find
what what they called abc weapons
atomic biological and chemical weapons
and the real threat at the time was
atomic weapons but very quickly samuel
goodsmith who was the head of
operational sauce he was a particle
physicist
he learned sitting in an
abandoned apartment of one of the
scientists in strasbourg france in
november of 1944
that the atomic program was nothing that
we thought it was and the reason was was
because as hitler told his minister of
armaments albert speer
atomic
science is jewish science so let's not
concentrate on that i'm paraphrasing him
but you get the idea
but hitler was very interested in
chemical weapons and biological weapons
and what samuel goodsmith learned in
that apartment in alsace
was that
the reich was experimenting with these
weapons on humans
that had been called from concentration
camps and this was the first time that
this information became available
to
american military intelligence
uh alsace director samuel goodsmitt came
across
this man
um in a letter and this is dr kurt bloma
he was the deputy surgeon director of
the third reich it's very difficult to
imagine that bloma later became part of
operation paperclip and certainly at the
time that goodsmith found out this
information he probably would have never
believed that and later he actually
wrote in his memoirs that he could not
believe that
also in those documents that goodsmith
came across
was
dr walter schreiber
surgeon general of the third reich
also later became part of paperclip and
would wind up living in texas
dr schreiber was in charge of the
vaccine program for the reich so
while blohm was heading up the
biological weapons
division
the reich was trying to create a bubonic
plague weapon
but at the same time
the reich knew that they needed to
create a vaccine against such a weapon
because were they to unleash this on the
allied
forces
their own soldiers would be you know
subject to this kind of
biological agent if they didn't have a
vaccine so schreiber here was in charge
of the vaccine program
and
to do that he was working with
concentration camp inmates
so
here we have speer i just want you to
remember him he comes up later and
hitler in paris
and this is of course goring who's the
head of the luftwaffe he was also the
head of all
science at the for the third reich under
a umbrella program called the reich
research council
and the third part of this triangle
which plays into operation paperclip is
heinrich himmler and here you see
himmler who's the head of the ss he's
the reichsphere ss
but he's also in charge of this vast
network
of state-sponsored slavery which has
been reinstituted
and the slaves are used to build weapons
for the reich
at the same time it becomes apparent
that the third reich is crumbling and so
stashes begin to happen and these are
this is a very famous photograph of
a huge trove of money that was found in
a
cave but also across the third reich
military intelligence
officers begin stashing weaponry and
more importantly documents related to
how those weapons are built so suddenly
alsace is on the move and they're
looking for weapons they're looking for
documents and they're looking for
scientists
if you see this little innocuous looking
tunnel up there that's an example
of one of the uh slave labor facilities
that the slaves that himmler was
organizing and shipping off to the
various
scientific and weaponry departments this
up here is nordhausen and this becomes
very important to the rocket program
because this is where the v2 rockets are
being built
and if you see here on the on the bottom
here this is inside of that cave and
entire trains could go in
and they as i write in the book
uh rocket parts would go in
and full rockets and bodies would come
out because the laborers were worked to
death
so the scientists are rounded up and
they're sent here to castle cranberry
um now the war is at its end
so we're now moving into may of 1945
and the military is in charge of this
castle and it's called dustbin as a
nickname and the scientists are set up
there and they begin to be interrogated
and when i went to germany
and i went through a lot of the
different bundes archives
i was fascinated reading some of these
original transcripts of these scientists
and these are sort of 70 page documents
which show in a very subtle way
how this program began so you have these
military intelligence officers
learning about hitler's nerve agent
programs that we did not know about
learning about hitler's biological
weapons programs that we did not know
about
interviewing the scientists and trying
to find out all that we can but also you
see decisions being made and that real
decision comes down to this should this
scientist
be hanged or should this scientist be
hired
um this here is castle cranberg it was
very interesting the scientists were all
walking around here you had spear out in
the garden
walking around to himself you had carl
brandt hitler's physician leading
gymnastics some of the scientists would
give lectures
and all the while they're going in and
out of these little rooms and being
interrogated by these different american
military officers
underneath the castle and remember this
was goring's one of goring's luftwaffe
headquarters during the war now we're in
charge of it
and under the castle there was this
bunker which was
where hitler planned to go with his
inner circle in the event that the reich
made the decision to use nerve agents to
use sarin gas which plays an important
role in operation paperclip
and you know why that nerve agent was
never used remains one of the great
mysteries of the war
we
allied intelligence discovered these
giant bunkers filled with bombs ready to
be loaded onto luftwaffe planes that
contained sarin gas but hitler never
gave the order but he had albert speer
design this bunker for him in the event
that he did give the order this is where
they were going to hang out
so again it was this great sort of
mysterious irony that this is where the
scientists were held who invented these
nerve agents
these are some of the guys who were in
castle cranberg and we'll get to their
stories in a moment
meanwhile
you've got something else going on at
nordhausen which is
the rockets and these officers that are
there are realizing
the the incredible breadth and scope of
the rockets the v2 rockets that that
were there
and they had orders to gather a hundred
of these rockets and to bring them back
to
the united states that they could be
launched out in new mexico
but then suddenly they come across
not only the rocket
plural
but they come across the scientists and
this is von braun right after his
actually he wasn't captured he
surrendered
he knew how important he would likely be
to allied intelligence and he was right
um and also with von braun who's sort of
been left out of this story is general
dornberger he became an american hero
and you see him there in his leather
coat which he liked to wear because the
reich's fuhrer ss wore that same coat
doernberger was von braun's boss and he
later became one of the most important
players in paperclip he recruited for
the pentagon he would fly back and forth
to germany looking for more german
scientists
he had a top secret clearance uh into
the middle 50s and he was really a
favorite
in the washington inner circle
when i started reporting the program
this was one of the only photographs i
could really find of the rocket
scientists
whoops
and then there you have just so you can
get an idea how quickly
we brought these rockets over and the
scientists and there it is um just a
couple years after the war
the first v the rocket v2 rocket that's
an actual v2 rocket um carrying albert
the first monkey astronaut
albert didn't
survive back to the chemical weapons so
that sarin gas i was speaking of this is
dr otto ambrose
and i think
if i would have to say one of the more
nefarious elements of operation
paperclip and i i'm not going to tell
you all the narratives that are in the
book but i will tell you one briefly
about dr ambrose and the reason why
i think his story is just so horrific is
that
ambrose was
hitler's favorite chemist and i say that
literally
he invented the sarin gas for the reich
but he also invented synthetic rubber
which was extremely important because
tanks need treads aircraft need wheels
and the synthetic rubber that was
produced was so important
to hitler that he awarded ambrose here a
one
million reichsmarks bonus
a document i found in the national
archives which had never been written
about before
that's how important ambrose was
and further
the reich was building synthetic rubber
at auschwitz
so this here is a satellite photo from
1944 june
and you have auschwitz berkey now and
the gas chambers up there but down in
the lower corner here you have a slave
labor facility run by ig farben who is
the chemical company that also produced
zyklon b
and they were making synthetic rubber
down there and otto ambrose who would
later become part of paperclip
uh was in charge of that facility
of all the photographs that i came upon
in researching this book
and we all know those
you know horrific photographs of the
bodies as cordwood
nothing disturbed me more than this
photograph and that's because of what it
says
it says company sporting club ig
auschwitz up top and those are two of
otto ambrose's colleagues fencing as
they would in the evening after a long
day of what they thought was hard work
at the laboratory there at auschwitz but
as i learned from colleagues academics
at the fritz bower institute who gave me
permission to republish this photograph
this was well within the view of the
chimneys at auschwitz
so
bloma is captured
and
he cooperates with allied intelligence
he's the first
high-ranking member of hitler's inner
circle that speaks of
atrocities mass sterilization and
gassing of jews he becomes a key player
in this
story because he's the first person who
cooperated
but at the same time you have
colonel harry armstrong
who is a top physician
for what was then called the army air
forces later the u.s air force
and uh armstrong was on a mission
in berlin looking for
nazi doctors he called them german
physicians
and
for many years the the idea of the
fiction was that they were german
physicians
but really
i and others before me
have put together the very clear picture
of what most of these men were doing
during the war
and you see them here their photograph
this photograph never been printed
before
um
this is 34 of the top leading physicians
who worked in a classified program one
of the very first programs that was part
of operation paperclip inside germany in
heidelberg
starting you know days after the war
ended
because that the army air forces knew
that to bring these men to the united
states
so quickly would would never fly and so
they had them working there in
heidelberg
later 34 of them
would uh
join harry armstrong at a facility in
texas
hubert is struggled the father of space
medicine we'll get to a little more
about him in a moment
but in the meantime as all those doctors
that i just showed you the photograph of
were working at heidelberg under harry
armstrong another element of military
intelligence came knocking and there
they had information that six of these
doctors were wanted for war crimes and
so six of them
went off to nuremberg these three would
become part of paper clips some before
some after
um
this is dr theodore benziger he was one
of the ones that was taken away to
nuremberg but what i was so
you know
really startled by was when i first read
about theodore benzenger i read his
obituary in the new york times which was
published in 1999
and uh it spoke it louded his career for
naval intelligence
he was a physiologist for the navy
and
it talked about how he invented the ear
thermometer and what great contributions
he had given to military medicine but it
never mentioned his wartime work and
what i found
in berlin were documents that showed
that benziger was on the original list
of criminals that were going to be tried
at the nazi
at the uh doctor's trial
at nuremberg but he was mysteriously
released just a few weeks before the
trial he was turned over to custody of
the u.s army air forces and he was
brought to america
that's the nazi doctors trial you see
bloma in the middle he was acquitted he
would later work for paper clip
dr beaglebock i write about him at
length in the book
and one of the only surviving
witnesses to the uh what went on in the
concentration camps called holland
reiner
amazing story i think in in the book
very dramatic it's amazing how these
little nuggets are lost to history when
i was reading the trial transcripts i
discovered when holland reiner was put
on the witness stand um
because the doctor that you just saw
removed a piece of his liver without
anesthesia
they were trying to test
how long someone could survive in the
ocean a downed pilot and how long how
much seawater you could drink so they
were simulating these tests
written by the other doctors who would
later come to texas
um but holander was so angry he had a
dagger hidden in his pocket
and he left off the witness stand and he
ran to the dock to try to stab dr
biegelbach it's this incredible moment i
couldn't believe i had never heard of
this before
and then the great tragedy of it was the
judge the american judge who really
believed firmly that we were at
nuremberg to show how democracy works
put hollenrider in the prison with the
very doctors who had done this to him
dr stroghold was in charge of all the
nazi doctors that worked for the
luftwaffe he became our father of space
medicine and there he is with the
library that was was named after him
which was ultimately taken down
you know
the program went all the way up to the
pentagon and the joint chiefs of staff
were in charge of the program
and when you when i would read over some
of these documents it was fascinating
how you could really see the difference
you could see some of the military
generals who were reporting to the joint
chiefs
were just pained at having to bring
these individuals here to the united
states to work on our weapons programs
but it was also kind of shocking to me
that some of the generals
did not feel that way at all they
actually
respected and admired some of the nazi
scientists
and i was surprised to find that this
was one of them general lux was in
charge of the chemical core and i don't
say this lightly and i don't um i mean
it's very important that one has as a
journalist one has the documents to back
this up the nerve agent program is still
largely classified but i traveled to the
u.s army military history institute in
pennsylvania to look at general lux's
papers and it was there that i found
these uh personal diaries
that he wrote which told much of the
story which i report in paperclip
there you see luke's at
a party he's having
and
it was in those papers that i discovered
that
ss brigade fear walter scheiber
sheber excuse me uh
never known to be part of operation
paperclip but he was he was so
close to himmler he was on himmler's
personal staff
and he wore you can see that little
button there
that's actually the golden party badge
and that was given out by hitler to his
closest entourage
and he was a chemist
and he became very friendly with general
lukes who i just showed you the
photograph of and the two men exchanged
christmas cards for many years which are
also in the military uh
institute in pennsylvania
just to give you an idea of how close
shiba was to the top these are
photographs that the bundes archives
does not let one reprint but i'm happy
to show them here
um there's shiber with spear and milch
and there he is shaking hands with
hitler
so those are uh general luke's diary and
i'm just going to sort of end here with
just a little bit about reporting a
story which i think is interesting i
hope
um
about bringing new information to the
table because so much of this has been
you know gradually written about in bits
and pieces over the years but when you
come across something like these diaries
it's really incredible to me because i
really do believe in the idea that more
always gets revealed and curiosity
you know helps a journalist and if you
look and look and you're willing to keep
looking you will find
and these are luke's journals and in
them you know here is this incredibly
classified program so classified it's
still classified and yet you have
general luke's you know that human in
all of us that sort of wants to write in
our journal
you know attended conference with
dr walter sheber classified matters
and it was from this kind of information
and it is from this kind of information
that i am usually able to piece together
the most interesting part of my stories
because as a journalist once you have a
bit of information you can go to the the
powers that be that are telling you no
no no there is no information and you
can kick the door in a bit and discover
these documents by filing different
kinds of freedom of information act
requests based on
facts that are known and very
importantly dates as you see in in this
journal
and from that i was able to locate this
document which is
pretty much the highest ranking
um
war criminals that worked with
uh hitler's nerve agent program and that
was the list of people that general
lukes would have at his home
on saturday afternoons
as a round table discussion and they
would um learn the secrets of the sarin
gas program which was then brought back
to america and allowed the united states
to build up its sarin gas program and if
anyone has been reading about syria's
chemical weapons programs today we know
that the ones that are being dismantled
now are
sarin gas weapons so this is a long
legacy
i was also able to work with some of the
children of hitler's inner circle by
interviewing them
in berlin very brave individuals who
you know as they are getting older 70s
and 80s most of the children are you
know some of them were remarkably
transparent with me and shared their
parents
personal papers and that really allowed
me to bring some interesting
uh things to the table that i don't
think have been reported before and also
some photographs this is shiber by the
way um
and by 1952
he was working for the cia
some of the war criminals were sent to
prison this is landsberg prison where
they went
some of them were hung those are the
unmarked graves
they were able to pray in this lovely
church
but ultimately the cold war was getting
hot and john mccloy
here with truman became u.s high
commissioner of germany
and uh
and he
gave clemency to the majority
of the war criminals who were in
landsberg prison and they were released
and this here is otto ambrose at
nuremberg he's the chemist hitler's
favorite chemist with the one million
reichsmark bonus
um when he he was convicted of mass
murder and slavery
he might have had some foresight perhaps
which is why he's laughing that he would
one day soon be released
but not only was he released his
finances were fully restored
this is the world's what i would call
the the cia's first
black site
right after the war the cia
well actually in 1947 after the cia
began teamed up with naval intelligence
army intelligence and air force
intelligence at this place and used some
chemists and some chemistry that had
been developed by the nazis and began
enhanced interrogation techniques using
lsd and street drugs on what was now
soviet block prisoners because this was
the cold war
the two physicians at that facility
none other than dr schreiber and dr kurt
bloma
the reason that bloma got the job was
because schreiber was sent to texas
and schreiber worked at the u.s air
force for the u.s air force in texas
and it's a long and tangled tale you can
read about it in the book but it's
really astonishing that schreiber
the former surgeon general of the third
reich was living in texas
but as i said the cold war was heating
up and this was the threat the threat
was that the soviets who by the way had
their own program of german scientists
um
they they got a lot of rocket scientists
but unlike
our program we sort of put the german
scientists up on pedestal
pedestals and treated them with great
regard and made them sort of the top
dogs of our program
the soviets really load the germans
there was deep animosity from the war
and so their german rocket scientists
were kept at a second tier
and they were actually
squeezed of the information
and sent back to germany by the russians
at which point the cia stepped in
grabbed up all those german scientists
to try to learn what they could about
the soviets missile program but what
they learned was nothing because the
soviets didn't share with the german
scientists that top tier of information
we moved forward with our biological
weapons program this is the eight ball
dr blum consulted on this and this is
where we tested our bubonic plague
weapon
likewise our sarin gas weapons
and warner von braun became the head and
the hero
of the nasa space program there he is
with jfk
arthur rudolph father of the saturn
rocket i write at length about his story
in um operation paper clip it's really
just remarkable how he went from
a guy without a without a college
education running the slave labor
tunnels at nordhausen to being
father of the saturn rocket in the
united states he was one of the very few
paper clips who was actually
investigated and in the 80s the
department of justice
got some information it's funny that the
department of justice would have to get
information declassified but they did
and they were able to see his complicity
in war crimes in those in those tunnels
and they gave him an option as an old
man he could either stand trial in the
united states this was in the mid 80s or
he could return to germany he chose to
return to germany
and lastly and i think
most peculiar to me is um kurt debbis
who you know just those dueling scars
alone make him look slightly sinister
but uh many people regard debuts as
an american hero and told me so
i found out a very different um story
researching his
thick dossier declassified now
um one of the myths of the german
scientists was that they were just
trying to do science and they were sort
of skirting around trying to stay out of
the eye of the of the nazi party who was
this big bad wolf
but you find out um in reading closely
at the now declassified documents about
debuts that he actually turned his
superior another scientist
over to the gestapo during the war for
making anti-hitler remarks
and again that remarkable push and pull
when i was reading these documents you
could see
one part of army intelligence saying to
the pentagon you know we can't bring
this guy to the united states he was an
ardent nazi he turned a colleague over
to the gestapo this was a malicious they
used that word this was a malicious act
but then you see the pentagon saying we
need him and he came
there he is as the first director of the
jfk space center
and every year
still the national space club gives out
the kurt davis award
when i recently interviewed the head of
the space club and i said but what do
you say
when someone asks you
what about kurt davis he wore the ss
uniform to work
he turned over a colleague to the
gestapo
he was an ardent nazi what do you say to
that
and the answer was no one has ever asked
me that question before
so
i'd like to end with the idea that
einstein really had it right in my
opinion
he left germany
um prior to
hitler's armaments build up and he
always maintained that the reason he
left as a scientist was because he was
not going to work for a raw and rabid
nazi militia
there he is getting his citizenship
and he's one of the few people with
power that petitioned truman not to have
operation paperclip happen but to no
avail
and my last thought is this which is
written over
the gate
at buchenwald yadam das zaina
and it's an old german proverb
that says everyone gets what they
deserve
and when i was reporting this book
and i was writing this book i would
often ask myself
does everyone really get what they
deserve
and i hope that you
if you choose to read operation paper
clip
come to your own conclusion
thank you very much
[Applause]
so i have some time for some questions
yes in your research uh beyond the lsd
stuff did you come across anything about
the techniques used to split people's
personality and mk ultra did you find
anything about that coming out of
research that was started in the death
camps
well i don't know about splitting
personalities but i do know that camp
king that photograph that i showed you
excuse me that is where the mk ultra
program began it had two operational
code names
prior to mk ultra one was operation
bluebird and one was artichoke and they
began
that scenario that i that i spoke of
during the presentation and i also write
about in the book
yes
yeah two questions um
what were the theories why the nerve gas
was never used i know you said you had
questions about it what were the
theories and to bring these people
out were any vatican passports used
the first part of the question about uh
why chemical weapons weren't used
i would say the prevailing theory is
that because when hitler was a soldier
in world war one he missed the end of
the war because he was gassed
and mustered gas and so
allegedly he had a deep aversion to
chemical weapons but
the nazis produced
tens of thousands of tons of nerve agent
so
there was so many
individuals
under his command that really wanted to
use those nerve agents
it really is nothing short of a miracle
that it wasn't used
your second question was
um
with many of the nazis vatican passports
were used to mainly take to argentina
and then back to the states
well unfortunately for operation paper
clip there was no need to do that
because the the nazi scientists who came
to america were given good old american
visas and later
became u.s citizens
yes in the back
i have a real mixture of feelings i'm
both slightly nauseous and also very
can't wait to get my hands on your book
i was actually living in north thousand
when
um it was bombed uh because of the b2
operation
and
we left my father was also one that
worked for benner from brown
and after the war in 1950
my mother was actually also a cic agent
before it became a cia
to identify nazis before as they were
trying to leave the country and
but my question was i we left munich in
1950
and we
you know my father my stepfather was
actually my stepfather had stayed gone
back and forth to geneva because he was
one of the scientists that either
americans or russians were vying for
and
there are questions that i have we left
germany in 1950 51
he didn't take either of the offers he
decided to go to damascus syria
instead with 10 other german rocket
scientists who had worked with von braun
and i've never quite understood i was
only 10 years old at the time i never
first of all we left with
non-german passports we left with arabic
passports
my name was viodeletta issa
and every time the conductors came in to
check passports i had to look out the
window i wasn't my mother said don't
talk
so my question has always been
you know
there's so much that i don't know
because as a child
you know you just sort of live with it
an american ambassador uh actually
helped us leave damascus my father came
to america with us we came together
when there was a coup in 1953 in syria
and he wound up working for lockheed he
became the head of the missile test
program
in the santa cru santa cruz mountains
one of the other scientists rudy baiko
worked in sacramento and worked for
aerojet for 40 years and was very
instrumental in in developing
the bicycle cycle it's so fascinating
maybe you can stay afterwards and speak
with me i'd love to and did you have a
question
i wanted to know about how did the other
german scientists how did so many of
them who did leave
you know how did they actually
why did they use arabic passport and why
did they not
was it because they were nazis they come
talk to me afterwards the the the middle
eastern connection is very interesting
and it's not part of operation paperclip
per se but we can chat after thank you
very much
yes did you find in your research at all
about plum island new york and what
happened there around
genetically modified organisms lyme
disease
that whole thing did you
general lukes who became very friendly
with the um chemists was in charge of
setting up plum island
and
eric traub who was worked under dr blom
uh was in charge of the
weaponizing rinder pest
and also
tularemia for the reich
and troub is often connected with plum
island
he came to the united states he worked
for um the navy he worked for the
department of agriculture and
there's a lot of suggestion that he also
set up plum island and worked there
but
i could find no official documents
that made that connection sound but it
certainly is
reasonable speculation
good question yes
yeah during the 1960s 66 67
there were people in this country who
were trying to confront the justice
department to say we had a lot of nazi
war criminals here
and why don't you find them and either
put them on trial or deport them
to jurisdictions where they should be
put on trial
and dealt with and the justice
department always said we don't have any
nazi war criminals in this country and
besides you people who are asking the
questions
are leftists and communists
and we're not interested in what you
have to say but they did have an office
in the 1960s to to address the issues of
whether people were nazi were criminals
they just couldn't find any i'm
wondering did you come across any reason
yes it's it's a great point you bring up
and
twofold answer one
a number of individuals in the state
department because the state department
was an important part of operation paper
clip on this end because the state
department was the organization that had
to give those visas
and there was a couple individuals one
in particular named samuel claus who was
outraged by this program
but he was very quickly accused of being
a communist and he was moved out of the
state department
the reason why to answer the second part
of your question the reason why arthur
rudolph was ultimately investigated by
the justice department was that you know
lo and behold throughout the 60s and 70s
and early 80s different organization
groups often jewish organizations
would sort of muck wreck so to speak
and get try and get the justice
department to look into this
and ultimately they did and a special
unit was created
only in 1980 that looked at these war
criminals
yes
did the
nazi scientists who were brought here
how did they justify the work that they
were doing
they were supposedly working for mankind
not killing it
as a scientist
and did they show any remorse for what
had been done
it's a great question um the first part
is
no there was
remember that there was
most there was not even a sliver of
accountability on the part of the
scientists they always denied that they
were part of it i mean dr bloma
although he originally started to talk
to the um
military officers about what went on
very quickly it became
what they did not me and that was always
the position always always always and as
far as remorse is concerned there was
only one
nazi physician out of all of the
scientists that i looked at
who showed any remorse and that was a
doctor named dr fritz fisher and during
the nuremberg trials after he heard a
particularly gruesome bit of testimony
by some survivors um he turned to the
one of the intelligence officers dr
leopold alexander who's really one of
the heroes of the book and he said just
hang me now
but that was it
it right here yes
two quick easy or i'll same quick you
could take as long as you want uh
first is
another notorious person from world war
ii who was involved with experiments and
obviously not part or in navy's people
part of paperclip was mengele
and even now there are moral issues that
are at stake about using the information
that he garnered from some of his
experiments
is your book touching that at all
mengele i actually write about in my
area 51 book but not in paper clip i did
not come across any other information
about him as far as we know he you know
he was in germany for a while and then
he went to south america but the the
question that you raise about the
uh information used is extremely
important and what i will tell you is
that
there's a
there's a two-part u.s air force
physiology manual which is very
difficult to get your hands on
that actually used data
from the concentration camps and
you see the credits and the footnotes go
to those doctors that i showed you the
photograph of that were hauled off to
nuremberg one of whom dr hermann becker
freising was actually sending notes to
dr strughold for that u.s
air force manual from his prison cell at
landsberg prison the other question is
leaving
the responsibility of the nazis who he
brought over
and coming to the americans who made it
happen
let's go to the top is there anything
you found about truman's awareness
approval or anything else oh truman
approved the program um i'm sorry if i
left that out and here we are on
president's day um
you know the operation paper clip was a
classified military program but it had a
benign public face
so
the joint chiefs knew that if you
started having you know upwards of
sixteen hundred german scientists
running around somebody was going to
catch on to the fact that this was going
on and so they propagated this
myth that these were benign scientists
that truman bought or did was he in on
the myth is the question i guess i'm
asking i don't believe from my research
that neither truman nor eisenhower
really had access to the actual dossiers
you know they would not as president
have
even asked to know and certainly
it would have been kept from them so
they approved the program
as it was sold to them from my
understanding
way in the back
uh this is uh
fascinating and important
and had i not stumbled
upon
the blurb in the book passage
calendar i never would have known about
any of this
um and so my question to you is uh in
sort of the broader context of the short
attention span circus that we call
the media mainstream media what has been
your experience in trying to get out
word about this
well the book just published six days
ago and and it's doing remarkably well
considering the story is 69 years old so
i give a lot of credit to uh
my fellow readers who i i just really
think
i think we're all a really interesting
educated bunch of people here in america
for the most part and really just want
to read and find out about things so
it's why i write books that are
seemingly you know obscure and secret
but ultimately they find readers which i
think is remarkable
yes right here is there any significance
to the name that the operation was given
oh yes great question um
well we have the classified program we
have the benign public face and you have
the same thing going on in germany where
these intelligence officers are tasked
with interviewing the scientists and
really trying to find out about them
and
it needed to be kept secret it being the
dark-hearted parts of some of these
scientists past and so a system was
devised whereby very discreetly
a paper clip would be placed on the top
of the file in a certain position to
indicate
this is an important file that somebody
needs to look at that somebody being an
individual who was pro
the program
i'm going to just take one more on the
way back
yeah maybe maybe you you said it
and and i i missed it but
was this a
did this program have a particular
purpose or was it just collecting random
important german scientists and and
doctors like what were the major
objectives and was there one person who
put it to together you mentioned this
general luke's
um
so p purpose and and who yes who
organized it well um
you know the nazis almost won the war i
mean there was a point where their
weaponry was so
much further along than ours was
uh
hitler and goebbels called it
wunderwaffe which was wonder weapons
and there was this idea that
you know suddenly dawned on the u.s
military we're really behind the curve
here and so as the war was ending that's
why that push came about which is we
have to grab this science and we need it
for our own weaponry i think one of the
most interesting conclusions i came to
in reporting book the book was that the
cold war really began
at the you know the in the last months
of world war ii
right there did you find anything that
comes forward to today like scientists
that are now at monsanto creating
genetically modified organisms or
fluoride i have a whole social media i
have hundreds of people asking me to ask
you
uh fluoride
fluoride seems to have come in our water
but it came from the nazi scientists so
did you find any of that there too
um fascinating question so
the nazi scientist program was
eventually rolled up into
another element of the department of
defense which is the office of research
and engineering
and that became darpa
which is the defense advanced research
project agency which is the subject of
my next book
shameless plug yes
yes
you said early on that the russians
returned their scientists back to
germany again
was there a reason for that
they couldn't stand the german
scientists
that's an interest i never thought of
that that is a very interesting question
but uh they sent them back to germany
and but the fascinating part we had a
program the cia's program was called
operation dragon return
and we scooped up anyone who had been in
the soviet union working on their
weapons programs and you know use them
as intelligence assets
yes
is it true that alan dulles was like
sort of a front man and it was actually
reinhard galen that was setting up the
cia
great question i write about galen at
length
he was at camp king
and um he was you know he was run by
galen was
the head of
uh hitler's soviet intel you know
program on
the soviet union intelligence program
and he became a major player um in all
of this sadly
and uh
his story is interwoven into paperclip
he was not part of paperclip but he was
at camp king with his
you know team of ss officers and former
intelligence agents and they all worked
they were run by the army intelligence
and then later the cia took them over
and so when we spoke of mk-ultra
the soviet bloc spies who were
tossed into the slammer at camp king
and subjected to those enhanced
interrogation programs were actually
caught in galen's web
and one more time
to speculate as to what impact this the
release of this new information might
have
based on sort of inquiries
i'm just wondering where you think this
may lead
well it's interesting i really believe
as i said earlier that you know more
gets revealed and i think that when
people are interested
um
it just it kind of creates a bigger web
of information and so hopefully my
reporting because it's just the tip of
the iceberg um
i i don't one of the things that i that
i mentioned i think it was earlier today
on a radio show was how ambrose was a
you know hitler's favorite chemist
convicted nazi war criminal
came to the united states on a u.s
department of energy contract
came to the united states three times in
the 1960s and while i couldn't get any
information
uh declassified about what ambrose was
doing and what his program was on and by
the way as i write in the book neither
could president ronald reagan
um who asked about it
but
i thought to myself well wait a minute
ambrose had to come to the united states
he's a convicted nazi war criminal
so i foied the state department a
freedom of information act request to
try to find out about his travels how he
came here and who he was being sponsored
by and uh that information was lost or
classified
it's probably not lost or classified i
couldn't find it out but i bet some
curious journalist sometime in the
future will
thank you adam
[Applause]
thank you all if you have a book please
come on up we'd like to purchase one
there at all the registers